i
en eeuu ahora podrán prohibir el aborto
la puerta la abrió este viernes la corte
suprema de justicia cuando cinco de los
nueve jueces votaron a favor de revocar
el derecho a la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo que aplicado para todo el
país desde 1973 con el histórico caso
del roe versus white con esto la
decisión dependerá de cada estado el ex
presidente de donald trump celebró el
fallo diciendo que era obra de dios
mientras que el mandatario joe biden
afirmó que su administración usará todos
los recursos legales para oponerse estas
posturas marcan una verdad evidente el
aborto será el tema determinante de las
elecciones de medio término en noviembre
en las que los republicanos y los
demócratas luchan por ganar la mayoría
en el congreso se prohibirá el aborto en
todo eeuu qué pasará con este derecho
que tanto impactará en las futuras
elecciones
antes de responder estas preguntas
miremos primero un repaso de cómo ha
sido la postura política en el país
norteamericano frente a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo
se jacta de ser el país de la libertad
hace casi 50 años eeuu legalizó el
aborto en todo el país la histórica
decisión del tribunal supremo de 1973 lo
estableció como un derecho
constitucional hasta la viabilidad es
decir hasta el momento en que un feto
puede vivir fuera del útero que ahora se
considera alrededor de las 23 semanas de
gestación
pero el caso roe versus weight también
suscitó movimientos anti abortistas
liderados por grupos religiosos que se
fueron politizando en 1967 renaut wigan
fue uno de los primeros gobernadores del
país en legalizar el aborto en su estado
california pero para ganar las
elecciones presidenciales de 1980 reagan
decidió que necesitaba el voto
evangélico así que cambió su postura y
se declaró contrario al aborto
whitmarsh no debemos descansar y les
prometí que no descansaré hasta que una
enmienda sobre la vida humana forme
parte de nuestra constitución
desde entonces los republicanos se han
redoblado y el movimiento ha ganado
terreno quiere que el tribunal anule la
sentencia de robert sus week
bueno si ponemos otros dos o quizás tres
jueces eso sucederá y eso sucederá
automáticamente porque estoy poniendo
jueces pro-vida en la corte road live y
just son de kurt durante su mandato
donald trump pre modelo dramáticamente
la corte suprema los jueces
conservadores ahora son la mayoría con
los derechos reproductivos en peligro y
después de darlo por sentado durante
muchos años los estadounidenses a favor
del aborto se están reuniendo
es una lucha que nos va a llevar a todos
a ganar y estoy aquí para decir que no
vamos a retroceder
de acuerdo
el 61 por ciento de la población dice
que el aborto debe ser legal en la
mayoría de las circunstancias
contrario a las posturas de varios de
sus predecesores el actual presidente
joe biden no sólo respalda el aborto
sino que reaccionó oponiéndose
abiertamente a la decisión que tomó la
corte suprema de justicia- invito a que
las protestas continuarán de manera
pacífica y advirtió que su gobierno
intentará encontrar las maneras para
proteger el derecho escuchamos lo que
dijo
con esta decisión la mayoría
conservadora de la corte suprema-
muestra lo extrema que es a lo lejos que
están de la mayoría de este país
y convirtió a eeuu en un caso atípico
entre las naciones desarrolladas del
mundo pero esta decisión no debe ser la
palabra final
mi administración utilizará todos sus
poderes legales apropiados
muestra el congreso debe actuar y con su
voto ustedes pueden actuar lo que no y
para analizar ese tema saludamos en
nueva york a paula ávila guillén
directora ejecutiva del women's y
quality sangre y abogada de los derechos
de las mujeres también nos acompaña
juliet gómez activista pro-vida abogada
y directora de la organización
colombiana damas celestes antes de
comenzar les recuerdo que ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de esta conversación dejen sus
preguntas y todos los comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en twitter instagram y facebook con con
el arroba france24
en mi cuenta personal mariah que aguirre
en youtube pueden seguir nuestra señal
en vivo y también los invito para que
escuchen el podcast de nuestro programa
estamos en app el podcast spotify deezer
y tuning participen con el numeral el
debate efe 24 y ahora sí comencemos
quiero explicar primero un poco la
decisión que tomó la corte suprema de
justicia y es que en 2018 el estado de
misisipí impuso una ley que prohibía el
aborto después de la semana 15 esta
decisión llegó a manos de la corte allí
seis de los tres magistrados decidieron
aprobar la ley de misisipí sin embargo
cinco de los nueve decidieron tumbar
además el caso roe versus wade que decía
que no se podía prohibir al aborto antes
de la semana 23 la decisión hace que los
estados definan lo que quieren hacer que
era lo que ocurría antes de 1973 y se
espera que al menos 26 estados prohíban
rápidamente la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo tras la nueva decisión
según un estudio del instituto
guttmacher 13 de esos estados tienen
leyes restrictivas que entran en vigor
de manera automática como ocurre en
kentucky luisiana y dakota del sur o en
menos de un mes como pasa en 10 estados
más todo esto hace que en la mitad del
país se restrinja el aborto le quiero
preguntar entonces y darle la bienvenida
ávila guillén como queda entonces el
derecho en eeuu después de que la corte
le retiró la protección legal
pues es realmente devastador esta
decisión es una decisión que tiene un
impacto en más de 35 millones de
personas especialmente de mujeres y que
va a afectar la salud y la vida
reproductiva y nuestro proyecto de vida
creo que algo que hemos visto en américa
latina que son países que tienen
restricciones es que si realmente
nuestro objetivo sería reducir los
números de abortos pues existen
políticas efectivas para hacerlo como
incluye el acceso a la educación sexual
el acceso al antes a los anticonceptivos
pero definitivamente sabemos que las
prohibiciones del aborto no llevan a
reducir los números de abortos sino por
el contrario lo que crean son
condiciones inseguras entonces en este
momento eeuu está creando un sistema de
clases aquellas personas que tengan
recursos y accesos van a poder acceder
al aborto y aquellas que no pues
sencillamente van a tener que arriesgar
sus vidas y le quiero dar la bienvenida
también a juliet gómez julia de usted
está de acuerdo con lo que dice paula de
que este fallo es devastador y crea un
sistema
para abordar
estoy totalmente en desacuerdo
de hecho si nosotros realmente lo que
entramos es hacer un análisis de la
situación y lo que ha pasado es falso lo
que está diciendo cuando dice que las
estadísticas demuestran que sube el
número que disminuye el número de
abortos realmente si hacemos un
recorrido desde precisamente el fallo
desde el inicio al fallo hasta la
actualidad nos damos cuenta que los
abortos incrementan entonces ni
educación sexual ni aborto justifica
realmente aprobar el homicidio de
personas por nacer por otra parte decía
algo de un sistema de clases y en eso sí
estoy de acuerdo lo que pasa es que ella
lo maneja con un enfoque contrario a la
realidad lo que está sucediendo en este
caso es que el aborto realmente lo que
está haciendo es favoreciendo esta
diferenciación de clases por así decirlo
en el cual las personas con menos
recursos están siendo asesinadas en el
vientre de las mujeres si se analizan
las clínicas un aborto ya son los
abortorios plantar en hood realmente
tiene un número y un índice superior en
estados en los cuales
o mayor número de personas extranjeras o
mayor número de
afrodescendientes o de personas de color
negro diferentes opciones como los
manejan diferentes formas como los dicen
pero lo que pasa es que eso no es lo que
se nota entonces lo que está pasando es
que se está dando prioridad a lo que
realmente importa y es el principal
derecho humano el derecho a la vida del
cual se desprende la libertad que tanto
se pide en eeuu y a nivel mundial ya voy
a volver con paula y con giulia al
respecto antes como les decía robert sus
weight señalaba que no se podía prohibir
al aborto antes de las 23 semanas que es
cuando se considera que el feto ya es
viable después de eso cada estado era
libre de regular y en la última década
la mayoría de los estados han intentado
restringir el aborto como lo muestra
este mapa con datos del instituto
guttmacher en ese sentido paula se
podría decir que la corte falló a favor
de los múltiples esfuerzos estatales y
que le respondería a juliette que habla
de homicidio de personas al nacer
pero yo creo que una cosa es cuando uno
habla bajo la ley s otra cosa es lo que
uno habla bajo el fanatismo eeuu es un
país en donde existen el menor número de
protecciones por ejemplo para la mujer
es el único país en el hemisferio en
donde uno está obligado a parir e ir a
perdón mi hijo está acá uno está
obligado quiere salir uno está obligada
para ir hay un al otro día
a trabajar es un país en donde no
existen protecciones por ejemplo para la
ayuda del cuidado de los niños razón por
la que esta calle a mí me aterra pensar
en que lo que estamos haciendo en este
momento es dejando a nuestros hijos con
menos derechos en este caso además tiene
implicaciones muy claras que va
muchísimo más allá del derecho al aborto
porque está hablando desde el derecho a
la privacidad de dónde puede intervenir
el gobierno y dónde no y ya lo dejó muy
claro también el juez thomas con su voto
concurrente que aquí no es donde van a
parar ellos también quieren prohibir las
libertades de escoger con quién tú
quieres formar una familia familia y
cómo formar una familia quieren prohibir
los derechos a los anticonceptivos
entonces esto no se trata del aborto se
trata de control el mensaje que la corte
suprema en este momento le estamos
enviando a las personas es que las vidas
de las mujeres valen menos que una niña
que tenga 11 12 13 años y sea violada
está siendo obligada para ir muchas de
estas restricciones que existen en
algunos de los estados están
respondiendo a esto
paula y usted mencionaba una postura muy
similar a la que tuvieron los cuatro
jueces de tendencia liberal que votaron
a favor de mantener la la sentencia o el
caso roe versus wade y es que ellos
alegan que no se le puede quitar los
derechos a las mujeres para dárselos a
los estados y que sean los estados
quienes decidan qué pasa con los cuerpos
de las mujeres juliette usted que piensa
al respecto
yo quisiera primero que analizáramos
algo y es que esto no es tema de
religión o de fanatismo porque también
existen por ejemplo los ateos pro-vida
siempre se tiende a llevar nuestro
activismo pro vida hacia simple y
sencillamente una cuestión de credos ok
no lo miremos desde los credos mirémoslo
desde la biología la biología es lo que
realmente está en duda en este caso la
biología es lo que no se cuenta la vida
inicia en el momento de la concepción
queramos o no creerlo eso es su cuestión
biológica si queremos hablar de
libertades yo también soy pro libertad y
también considero indispensable el
respeto a la libertad pero para que
exija el derecho a la libertad se
necesita vida porque tengo entendido
y la verdad es una verdad de perogrullo
los cadáveres no tienen libertad
para que podamos exigir la libertad de
mujeres la libertad de hombres de niños
de adolescentes de adultos mayores lo
primero que necesitamos es que el ser
humano tenga vida si nosotros queremos
realmente entrar a defender minorías
entrar a defender al ser humano entrar a
defender los derechos lo primero que
tenemos que respetar es el derecho por
excelencia
sin vida no hay libertad y eso es lo que
la corte ha entendido y está en este
momento defendiendo y está realmente
poniéndose la bandera de los verdaderos
defensores de los derechos humanos para
defender a un ser humano lo primero que
hay que tener es la noción de la vida y
para tener la noción de la vida hay que
tener una noción y un conocimiento así
sea básico ideología
y usted habla e insiste en el derecho a
la vida y la libertad sin embargo en
este debate del aborto la gran pregunta
es el derecho a la vida de quien si de
la persona gestante o del feto en este
caso le quiero preguntar a paula qué
pasa después de esta decisión de la
corte cuando el embarazo es producto de
una violación sexual o de un incesto o
cuando el embarazo pone en riesgo la
vida de la madre se podrá abortar en
esas circunstancias
pues mira van a ver muchísimos casos en
los que sencillamente no se puede
abortar van a ver muchísimos estados en
los que eso va a ser imposible y va a
ser además van a crear condiciones en
los cuales las mujeres que incluso
tengan pérdidas naturales del embarazo
van a tener que explicar como eso no fue
un aborto y eso es lo que vemos por
ejemplo en casos como los del salvador y
lo que hemos visto en américa latina y
entonces esto tiene afectaciones incluso
por embarazos deseados y creo que las
implicaciones de la vida siempre van de
la vida de que decían tiene que decidir
sobre nuestros días nuestros proyectos
de vida si nuestros futuros si realmente
quisiéramos concentrarnos a traducir los
números de amor todos entramos
y embarazo no deseado
y le quiero preguntar a yulia de una
pregunta que plantea paula y es quien
puede decidir sobre ese derecho a
abortar y sobre ese derecho a la vida
bueno yo creo que tenemos que entender
que con la decisión que tomó la corte ya
no podemos hablar del derecho a abortar
el derecho a cortar no existe existe el
derecho a la vida y eso sí es muy
importante que lo tengamos claro y que
quede marcado en la mente de todos
nosotros el derecho a la vida es un
derecho humano el derecho a abortar es
algo relativo y es algo más que va
digamos de una u otra manera de acuerdo
a los diferentes activismos y
movimientos que se pueden hacer de
diferentes organizaciones femeninas o
feministas en diferentes países o en
diferentes estados
el derecho a decidir del embrión o del
feto
sobre si quiere ir en quien recae eso es
algo que se está pensando
estamos hablando de cuál de las dos
vídeos vamos a salvar o de cuál vida
debe primar me pregunto dónde está la
regla dónde está el metro cómo sabemos
qué vida es más importante o qué vida es
más digna cuál es el parámetro para
saber de una u otra manera qué tan
merecedor es un ser humano de vivir
tiene que ser un ser humano cuyo
embarazo cuya vida desde el vientre es
deseada
yo no fui deseada por mi padre y acá
estoy muchos de las muchos de ustedes
muchas personas que están viendo esta
entrevista porque que hayan sido
personas que no fueron deseadas por sus
padres que bayas fueron bajo una
relación sexual simple y sencillamente
por un momento de placer eso los hace
menos dignos de vivir
realmente una persona con una
malformación congénita es menos digna de
vivir porque es una persona con una
enfermedad o una persona pobre es menos
digna me van a hablar del caso de las
violaciones porque entonces en este caso
se persigue la vida del fruto de un
delito y porque esa víctima está siendo
perseguida para liberar de la
responsabilidad al victimario y porque
una de las víctimas en este caso la
mujer que fue abusada sexualmente tiene
que pasar por la revictimización
en la práctica de un aborto son cosas
que realmente no se analizan porque
porque es que la cultura en la que
estamos en este momento tristemente nos
lleva esto a la celeridad a poder obviar
problemas y simple y sencillamente
seguir adelante sale mucho más práctico
evitar la vida de ese ser humano que fue
producto de una violación y que puede
sonar tal vez muy fea la forma en la que
lo voy a decir
que en el momento en el que ese embrión
pase a su época fetal o nazca puede ser
incluso la prueba 'reina' de la
violación y con eso se puede perseguir
al violador y realmente se puede
sancionar al victimario
ahora cuántas personas no pueden tener
hijos y si quisieran adoptar se permite
entonces con este caso o con mujeres que
pos daña su proyecto de vida un embarazo
que esas mujeres den en adopción a esos
niños porque porque se está salvando la
vida de menor no se está obligando a
quedarse con ese niño a esa madre y se
le está dando la oportunidad a una mujer
oa una pareja que no puede concebir
biológicamente de tener a sus hijos
realmente lo que está sucediendo en
torno al aborto es más que otra cosa
digámoslo como una especie de negocio
político que realmente se está manejando
para favorecer minorías y silenciar
mayorías sí aquí quiero preguntarle muy
brevemente a paula por dos afirmaciones
que da seguridad ella dice que el
derecho al aborto ya no existe en eeuu y
que se trata de un negocio político muy
brevemente que piensa usted para luego
continuar con más preguntas
claro eso no es correcto el derecho al
aborto sigue existiendo y va a seguir
existiendo en todos los estados que lo
protejan esa no es la decisión de la
corte y adicionalmente creo que esa
pregunta sobre cuál es el juicio
político de la ponderación a la vida que
tiene que tenerse en cuenta ya ha sido
resuelta por los jueces en los
tribunales se protege la vida ya formada
de forma proporcional a cómo se protege
la vida desde la concepción hasta el
momento en que sea viable y ese es el
juicio y el análisis que han hecho las
cortes tanto en colombia como en mexico
adicionalmente es hombre a mi me parece
que es absolutamente
irónico y yo no no puedo compartir de
ninguna forma una persona que considere
que una niña de 10 años violada sea
obligada a parir arriesgando su vida
arriesgando su cuerpo de 11 12 años o
los casos de mujeres en el salvador que
tienen pérdidas naturales de sus
embarazos y son sentenciadas a 15 30 ó
20 años de cárcel eso es algo que
sencillamente va más allá de lo humano y
que sólo pienso personas que no tienen
alma y no ha podido sentirse en esas
situaciones podrían pensar en apoyar
realmente creo que si queremos apoyar a
las mujeres que si se trata de apoyar a
las mujeres existen políticas públicas
que apuntan a las mujeres existen
políticas públicas en las que podamos
educación sexual ac acceso a
anticonceptivos apoyo aborto legal y
seguro es lo más rápido que se pueda
apoyo a post aborto ayudas a las mujeres
para que puedan tener derechos a la
maternidad no ser obligadas a parir y
tener que ir a trabajar al otro día a
que podamos tener acceso a servicios
para poder tener que nuestros hijos
puedan asistir a colegios a jardines
ayudas pero las mismas personas que se
oponen al aborto son las personas que se
oponen a todas estas políticas públicas
entonces creo que es sencillamente una
hipocresía dentro de muchas de las
peleas que supuestamente y de los
derechos que supuestamente defienden y
usted mencionó que en eeuu quedarán
algunos estados donde abortar si será
legal y de hecho ya se habla de que las
mujeres y las personas que quieran
abortar en otros estados y no puedan
hacerlo podrán viajar a donde si se lo
permita pero es una pregunta que le
quiero hacer a las dos comenzando por
paula que tantas barreras le impone esto
a las mujeres especialmente a las
comunidades más marginadas como las
afroamericanas
pues eso es exactamente lo que va a
pasar y lo que dije al principio es un
sistema de clases nosotras decimos las
ricas abortan las pobres se mueren y eso
es lo que va a suceder las mujeres que
siempre tengan recursos siempre van a
abortar independiente de cuál es el
estatus legal el estatus legal nunca ha
sido un impedimento para las mujeres que
tienen recursos para que aborten pero
siempre ha sido un impedimento para las
mujeres que incluso tienen embarazos
deseados y llegan a la clínica y se les
presenta alguna complicación y no
necesitan un aborto para poder salvarle
sus vidas para las mujeres que son
víctimas de violación para las niñas
entonces lo que va a suceder es que las
mujeres que son indocumentadas muchas de
ellas latinas no van a poder viajar van
a acudir a a recursos de poder manejar
sus propios abortos algunos seguros
algunos no y van a terminar muy
seguramente con consecuencias para su
salud esto crea un impacto
desproporcionado de mujeres negras en
mujeres latinas y en mujeres de bajos
recursos económicos las ricas abortan y
las pobres se mueren y esto afecta a las
indocumentadas latinas por ejemplo es lo
que dice paula juliette usted qué opina
al respecto
que la mujer que no tiene un verdadero
apoyo es la que haga vuelta
qué ha pasado en nosotros a través de un
recorrido bastante grande con
organizaciones conocidas a nivel mundial
como por ejemplo los 40 días por la vida
son organizaciones y todas las
organizaciones provida le préstamos
precisamente a la mujer lo que el aborto
y el feminismo les quita y es la
dignidad y el apoyo
cuando una mujer se encuentra frente a
un embarazo inesperado lo que menos
necesita de ser juzgada y muchas veces
es lo que piensan que nosotros como
pro-vida hacemos y es todo lo contrario
esas mujeres lo que necesitan es
escuchar saber que no están solas y es
el apoyo que nosotros como
organizaciones provida les prestamos
de eso también hay muchas mujeres que
por tener problemas económicos se ven
obligadas a abortar qué pasa las
organizaciones provida como realmente se
preocupan más allá de lo que pasa con la
mujer y apoyan esos embarazos les presta
el apoyo económico
en caso de que no quieran quedarse con
el bebé sea facilita y se apoya también
todo el trabajo legal que se necesita
para poder dar en adopción ese bebé
tanto a mujeres afro como a mujeres
latinas como a mujeres de escasos
recursos como a niñas como adolescentes
se les presta este apoyo porque nosotros
como organizaciones provida no
segregamos y no las categorizamos de más
o menos dignas ese embarazo merece más o
menos apoyo nosotros simplemente lo que
hacemos es tender una mano amiga y
decirles no está sola
si necesitas apoyo legal te lo brinda
necesitas apoyo económico te lo
brindamos necesitas apoyo con tu familia
te lo brindamos apoyo psicológico te lo
brindamos porque lo que una mujer busca
ante un embarazo de riesgo un embarazo
inesperado un embarazo no planeado
y ser escuchada ser apoyada compañía y
eso es lo que realmente nosotros como
organizaciones provida les prestamos
nosotros no les damos la espalda y
nosotros no las juzgamos cuando han
decidido abortar porque muchas mujeres
que forman parte del activismo otro vida
hoy en día son mujeres que han pasado
por la práctica de abortos y
precisamente conocen las consecuencias
de esas secuelas físicas
psicológicas emocionales
espirituales que quedan tras la práctica
de un aborto y ellas son las que más
defiendan la vida hoy en día además de
la discusión de qué tan válido o no es
el aborto uno de los temas que entra en
debate tras la decisión de la corte
suprema de estadounidense son las
tendencias políticas de los jueces y las
consecuencias y es que los cambios que
ha habido en la corte desde la
presidencia de donald trump son notorios
el mandatario dominó a tres de los nueve
jueces actuales que fueron amy cón y
parís
anabac y mil cursos esa es la mayor
cantidad nominada en un periodo
presidencial desde que richard nixon
estuvo en la casa blanca y con la movida
throne cambió la balanza y logró una
mayoría conservadora de seis jueces
frente a los tres de tendencia
progresista que ustedes ven en sus
pantallas y de hecho los tres que no me
nostrum votaron a favor de tumbar el
caso roe versus wait le quiero preguntar
a paula si se puede decir que esta
decisión del aborto es en parte una
consecuencia de la hera trump
antes de contestar a eso yo creo que
sería importante resaltar que las
organizaciones provida que
la orden persona está describiendo no
son las que confrontamos normalmente
existe un estudio del país de lo que son
los tres centros de crisis para el
embarazo en donde las mujeres son
maltratadas discriminadas porque deciden
abortar en donde las mujeres son
obligadas son das información falsa si
esto salió gracias a una investigación
que hicieron periodistas que se
filtraron en estos centros son
informaciones falsas que realmente
parecen noticias falsas diciendo que se
pueden volver pedofílicas si llegan a
tener un abortar o que van a tener
cáncer pues claramente es una
experiencia completamente diferente a
las que han vivido las mujeres que se
han enfrentado con estos centros de
crisis para la maternidad casi los
llaman que son patrocinados y
financiados por la industria pro-vida
entonces pues claramente es muy distinta
la experiencia para las mujeres del
común pero creo que es importante que
aclarar que definitivamente es
consecuencia de trump y lo que trump
hizo fue volver un tema algún tema
político el están politizando con
nuestros derechos estampó están
volviendo a nuestros cuerpos un cuerpo
de batalla política y creo que por eso
nuestra respuesta tiene que ser política
no puede ser una respuesta sencillamente
legal tenemos que ir a las calles
tenemos que marchar tenemos que
mostrarnos porque es la única forma en
que vamos a lograr que nuestras voces
sean escuchadas no podemos dejar que un
presidente que denomino a tres jueces en
un sistema que no estaba preparado para
ese tipo de repercusiones pues acabe
simplemente con nuestros derechos y esta
discusión legal se basa en un vacío
jurídico porque la constitución
estadounidense no otorga directamente el
derecho al aborto que es algo similar a
lo que había dicho juliette sin embargo
en 1973 la corte consideró que aunque no
estaba específicamente otros derechos si
hablaban de la integralidad de este
derecho y ahora la corte dice que no y
por eso tumba el roe versus wait ante
ese vacío el jueves conservador clarence
thomas ya dijo que también se debería
reconsiderar otros precedentes como él a
la anticoncepción en las parejas casadas
la anulación de la sodomía como un
delito e incluso el matrimonio
igualitario juliette ante esta
recomposición política de la corte se
puede retroceder en otros derechos
yo creo que más que retroceder es
avanzar porque estaríamos avanzando
precisamente se hace rescate de la
dignidad humana es que
desafortunadamente
el modernismo lo que nos ha llevado es a
pensar que el hombre es más digno en
cuanto a más liberal sea de su
sexualidad quiero que por un momento
solamente nos centremos en la parte de
la sodomía pienso que si realmente
nosotros re consideramos la dignidad del
ser humano a través de lo sexual y de
algo que realmente no es biológico no se
necesita entrar mucho en discusión al
respecto
la anticoncepción es precisamente lo que
dice el nombre ir en contra de que se
conciba un ser humano
el mal llamada de un matrimonio
igualitario la unión de parejas del
mismo sexo
también es una de las maneras en las que
no solo el libertinaje si seguir en
contra al núcleo de la sociedad que es
la familia se abandera hoy en día
decía a paula que esto realmente lo que
está es
volviéndose hacia lo político y es que
no se puede llegar así en este momento
no recuerdo cuál era la feminista que lo
decía creo si mal no estoy era a judith
butler que decía que lo personal es
político entonces a qué jugamos con ese
relativismo y esta doble moral de que
cuando el feminismo le conviene
politizar sus
decisiones sus derechos por llamarlo de
alguna manera sus más llamados derechos
ahí sí se puede entonces llevar
movimiento y que la onda política un
deseo pero cuando es un verdadero
derecho y es algo que dignifica y no me
canso de repetir esta palabra dignifica
al ser humano y cuando
restablece cuando recupera el derecho
principal de éste el derecho a la vida
ahí está mal visto y entonces tenemos
que volcarnos a las calles a defender lo
que muchas personas consideran derecho y
es asesinar a otro ser humano
si ya paulatinamente se ha ido
legalizando por decir palabras que no no
comparto que sea legalizar si no se ha
ido llevando hasta la tolerancia a
través de la ventana de o bertón
realmente este libertinaje cuando
ahorita por ejemplo asesinar un niño en
el vientre o cuando la bien sea y cosas
como la pedofilia que también se ha
legalizado en algunas partes
eso de una u otra manera nos va
mostrando como la destrucción de la
familia ha llegado a la sociedad
si muy brevemente le quiero pedir a
paula que diga cuál es su opinión frente
a lo que dice juliette de que este es el
rescate de la dignidad humana y que
realmente el libertinaje va en contra de
la familia
claramente no entienden la definición de
dignidad que ha sido establecida por los
múltiples tratados de derechos humanos
que incluye el la libertad de poder
tener tener control sobre nuestros
futuros sobre nuestros cuerpos sobre
nuestros destinos y las implicaciones
que esto tiene precisamente para las
familias a este tipo de leyes contra el
aborto son las que han separado familias
en muchos casos cuando las mujeres se
mueren o son llevadas a la cárcel este
tipo de leyes son las que han permitido
que exista por ejemplo la fertilización
in vitro que permite que muchas familias
puedan tener acceso a la ciencia para
poder formar sus familias entonces si
realmente nos interesan las familias
existen sistemas de políticas públicas
para proteger las familias y eso no
implica obligar a una niña de 10 años o
de 11 años a parir sí y ya para ir
concluyendo nuestro debate de julliard
le quiero pedir que muy brevemente nos
diga cuál es su conclusión de la
decisión que tomó la corte suprema de
justicia de eeuu
el derecho a la vida es el principal
derecho humano del cual se desprenden
las libertades que las diferentes
denominaciones liberales a nivel
político defienden la conclusión es esa
la corte ha entrado en razón y está
defendiendo el principal derecho humano
el derecho a la vida
y paula cuál es la conclusión que usted
da sobre esta decisión del aborto en
eeuu
es que sencillamente el mensaje que
envía la corte hoy a todas las niñas y a
todas las mujeres es que las mujeres no
podemos ser confiadas no podemos sembrar
que están libertades porque al ser dadas
esa libertad las vamos a usar que somos
ciudadanos de segunda categoría
paula o lila guillén y gómez gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 y
por plantear esta discusión tan
interesante que hemos tenido
gracias por la invitación
y ustedes sigan con nosotros aquí en
france 24
[Música]